I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello everyone this is Jenna Fisher. And this is Angela Kinsey. And today you're listening to Office Ladies and we will be breaking down Diversity Day. It's a good one. Season one episode two. This was written by BJ Novak and directed by Ken Quapis. It was. This was the moment for me. I was like, we have a hit. This is great stuff. Yeah. This was, oh my
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好，我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。今天你们收听的是《办公室女士》，我们将剖析《多元化日》。这一集很棒。第一季第二集。由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，肯·夸皮斯执导。没错。对我来说，这就是那个时刻。当时我就想，我们成功了。这太棒了。是的。这是，哦天哪
gosh, it's happening to me again. What's happening? I have so many things in my head to talk about this episode. It's like the little cards in my head are filtering and I don't know which one to pick first. Oh, like a Rolodex? Yes. Yes. Yes. That's what's happening. And then I freeze up. Then you freeze up and you kind of look like deer in headlights when I look at you. Yeah. I just stopped talking. I sort of shut down like a computer screen. You know what? The same thing happens to me at a buffet. I love a buffet. I can't decide. Too many choices. Too many choices. I'm like, do I want pancakes or do I want like the crab legs or their sushi? What buffet has crab legs and pancakes? Like
天哪，这种感觉又来了。怎么了？我脑子里有太多关于这一集的事情想说。就像我脑子里的那些小卡片在过滤，我不知道该先选哪一张。哦，像名片盒一样？对，对，对。就是这样。然后我就僵住了。然后你就僵住了，当我看着你时，你看起来就像被车灯照住的鹿。是的。我只是停止了说话。我像电脑屏幕一样关机了。你知道吗？我在自助餐厅也会发生同样的事情。我喜欢自助餐。我无法决定。选择太多了。选择太多了。我就在想，我是想要煎饼，还是想要蟹腿，或者是寿司？哪家自助餐有蟹腿和煎饼？比如
go to a buffet in Vegas. I love a Vegas buffet. Touche. Touche. Okay. Let's do it. All right. I'm going to start with a synopsis. You love it. That seems good. All right. In the episode Diversity Day, the staff of Dunder Mifflin must complete a diversity training seminar due to some complaints to corporate. But manager Michael Scott feels the training was insufficient and subjects the staff to his own training. Yes. That's it in a nutshell. That's it folks. And my gosh, I mean, it's just when I re-watched it, like it was so awkward. It's so awkward. This is like Michael Scott at his, his most cringy, this first season I feel like. Yeah. They really leaned in. They leaned in. Okay, Jenna, go. All right. Shall I start with some
去拉斯维加斯的自助餐。我喜欢拉斯维加斯的自助餐。说得好。说得好。好吧。我们开始吧。好的，我先来做一个剧情梗概。你喜欢这个。听起来不错。好的。在《多元化日》这一集中，邓德·米夫林的员工必须完成一场多元化培训研讨会，因为公司收到了一些投诉。但经理迈克尔·斯科特觉得培训不够充分，于是让员工接受他自己的培训。是的。简而言之就是这样。就是这样，伙计们。天哪，我的意思是，当我重温这一集时，它太尴尬了。太尴尬了。我觉得这是第一季中迈克尔·斯科特最让人尴尬的时刻。是的。他们真的投入进去了。他们投入进去了。好的，珍娜，开始吧。好的。我先从一些
fast facts? I am waiting. I can't wait to see what you got. I see. All right. So my first fast fact is that this was the first totally original script of the American version of the office because we talked about in the pilot that this was based on a British television show of the same name and the pilot episode was an adaptation of their script. This was not. After the pilot episode of our show, we started writing original storylines for our version of the show. That's right. Unique to the American, the office. That's right. And the writers referred to this episode as the pilot after the pilot. Oh, that's good little insight, guys. That's a little insight. The pilot after the pilot. Because they felt
速览开始？我等着呢。我迫不及待想看你准备了什么。我明白了。好的。我的第一个速览是，这是美版《办公室》第一个完全原创的剧本，因为我们在试播集里谈到过，它是基于同名的英国电视节目，而试播集是他们剧本的改编版。这一集不是。在我们节目的试播集之后，我们开始为我们的版本编写原创故事情节。没错。美版《办公室》独有的。没错。编剧们把这一集称为“试播集之后的试播集”。哦，这真是个很好的见解，大家。这是一个小见解。试播集之后的试播集。因为他们觉得
like this was establishing what is the American version going to be like? Oh, wow. Diversified it. Boy. That's, that's the pilot. That's it. Oh my God. I think when we think about this episode, Angela, we both talked about this. It is absolutely brilliant. And it's brilliant. People love it. And in rewatching it after all these years, I couldn't believe how remarkably it held up. Yeah. I mean, it's, it's just a stunning piece of comedy, in my opinion. And it was written by BJ Novak, who plays Ryan the Temp on the show. Also, you guys, it's like really smart. He is so smart. One of the smartest people I know. In time, him and Mindy were having a conversation, like, and I walked up and I was just like,
这确立了美版《办公室》会是什么样子？哦，哇。多元化了。天哪。这就是试播集。就是这样。天哪。我觉得当我们想到这一集时，安吉拉，我们都谈论过这一点。它绝对是天才之作。而且它很精彩。人们喜欢它。多年后重温，我简直不敢相信它竟然如此经得起考验。是的。我的意思是，在我看来，这是一部令人惊叹的喜剧作品。它是由在剧中饰演临时工瑞安的BJ·诺瓦克编写的。还有，伙计们，这真的很聪明。他太聪明了。他是我认识的最聪明的人之一。有一次，他和敏迪在聊天，我走过去，我就说，
Hey, and they were talking about sort of like some kind of advanced economics kind of conversation. And I was just like, okay, I'm okay. Bye. I think it's why Mindy and BJ became best friends was because they are just two of the smartest people in the world. They're so smart. They're the only people they can talk to. Well, I just knew in that moment, I had nothing to add to their conversation. And I just did the slow fade because I was like, wow, these are two really smart people. Well, let me lay something on you about BJ Novak in this episode. He was 25 years old when he wrote it. Shut the front door. What were you doing when you were 25 years old? Oh, Jenna. I'll tell you what I wasn't doing. I wasn't writing
嘿，他们当时在谈论某种高级经济学话题。我就想，好吧，我没事。再见。我想这就是敏迪和BJ成为好朋友的原因，因为他们是世界上最聪明的人。他们太聪明了。他们是彼此唯一能交流的人。好吧，那一刻我知道我没什么可补充的。我就慢慢退出了，因为我想，哇，这两个人真的很聪明。好吧，让我告诉你一些关于BJ·诺瓦克在这一集里的事。他写这一集时才25岁。关上大门。你25岁时在做什么？哦，珍娜。我告诉你我没在做什么。我没在写
a brilliant piece of television comedy. I was an operator at 1-800-Dennist. Yeah. I think I was working in a medical office as a receptionist. Yeah. Transcribing medical documents, which is interesting work, by the way. It sounds a little gross. Well, it was a psychological office. So what these psychologists did was if you were applying for an executive position at an important company, you had to go through a psychological evaluation. And then these psychologists would determine whether or not they could recommend you for the job or not. And you wrote it all down? I transcribed all of the sessions, all of the therapy sessions with the executives. Jenna, this sounds like an HBO series. Oh my gosh. You should pitch
一部精彩的电视喜剧。我是1-800-Dennist的接线员。是的。我想我当时在一家医疗办公室做前台。是的。转录医疗文件，顺便说一句，这是有趣的工作。听起来有点恶心。好吧，那是一家心理学办公室。所以这些心理学家做的是，如果你申请一家重要公司的高管职位，你必须通过心理评估。然后这些心理学家会决定是否推荐你担任该职位。你把这一切都写下来了？我转录了所有会议，所有与高管的治疗会议。珍娜，这听起来像是一部HBO剧集。天哪。你应该推销
that. Okay. Sorry. We're getting off topic. Well, I want to say in my time doing it, there was only one person who was not recommended. And it was because they felt he had some violent tendencies. Okay. Well, this is taking a turn. But can you imagine how suspenseful it was for me to be typing out that information? I was like, what are they? 25-year-old Jenna was like, ooh. Yeah. Well, that's what I was doing when I was 25. When BJ Novak was 25 years old, he was writing this television show. And this was his first job writing for a television show. I know. All right. I know. And his first script was Diversity Day. What the hell is going on? BJ, just settle down on being such an achiever. Okay. Can you just
那个。好吧。抱歉。我们跑题了。我想说，在我做这份工作期间，只有一个人没有被推荐。这是因为他们觉得他有一些暴力倾向。好吧。这话题变得有点沉重了。但你能想象我打出那些信息时有多紧张吗？我就想，他们是什么人？25岁的珍娜当时想，噢。是的。好吧，这就是我25岁时在做的事。当BJ·诺瓦克25岁时，他在写这部电视剧。这是他第一份电视编剧工作。我知道。好吧。我知道。他的第一个剧本就是《多元化日》。这到底是怎么回事？BJ，别再这么有成就感了。好吧。你能
relax? I had to reach out to BJ because I wanted to ask him, BJ, what was it like? Because here we had the British version of the show that was so acclaimed. And you are now tasked with writing the first original episode. The pilot after the pilot. The pilot after the pilot. He explained the original writing staff for the office was Greg Daniels, the executive producer showrunner, Paul Lieberstein, Mindy Kaling, Mike Scherr, and BJ Novak. What a room, by the way. Right. What a room. I know. And then they had Larry Wilmore and Lester Lewis who were consulting. This room full of writers broke down the plots and storylines of the five remaining episodes of season one. And they did this as a group. So they created
放松点吗？我不得不联系BJ，因为我想问他，BJ，那是什么感觉？因为我们有备受赞誉的英版节目。而你现在被委以重任，编写第一个原创剧集。试播集之后的试播集。试播集之后的试播集。他解释说，《办公室》最初的编剧团队是执行制片人兼剧集主管格雷格·丹尼尔斯、保罗·利伯斯坦、敏迪·卡灵、迈克·舒尔和BJ·诺瓦克。顺便说一句，这阵容太强了。没错。这阵容太强了。我知道。然后他们还有拉里·威尔莫和莱斯特·刘易斯担任顾问。这个编剧室里的人一起拆解了第一季剩余五集的剧情和故事线。他们是作为一个团队来做的。所以他们为
outlines for each of these episodes. And then a different writer got assigned a different outline and he got assigned the Diversity Day episode. Okay. So wait, I just want to make sure I understand. So they would take storylines and outlines and break them down as a group. Yes. And then you would get assigned which storyline was yours. Yes. And then you had to fill in the dialogue and different story points and, you know, you do a good amount of writing on your episode, but the idea for the episode comes from the group collective. From the room. Okay. Right. And also at that time, they didn't know what order they were going to air. So he did not have the pressure.
每一集都创建了大纲。然后不同的编剧被分配到不同的大纲，他被分配到了《多元化日》这一集。好的。等等，我想确保我理解了。所以他们会把故事情节和大纲拿出来，作为一个团队进行拆解。是的。然后你会被分配到属于你的故事情节。是的。然后你必须填入对话和不同的故事点，你知道，你在你那一集上做了大量的写作工作，但这一集的想法来自集体。来自编剧室。好的。没错。而且当时他们不知道播出顺序。所以他没有压力。
Yes. Because that's why I was thinking. Writing the first one. Yeah. That would be, that would be so much pressure. That's, I would freeze up. And I remember that. I remember that when we came back after getting picked up and we were going to shoot these five additional episodes, we had five completed scripts and then they decided which one they were going to shoot. If they didn't come out weekly, they did it collectively before we started the season, which I guess that takes some of the pressure off. It would. Yeah. And I have another fast fact. All right. You do your fast facts because I've got some delicious note cards waiting for you. All right. Some Kinsey tidbits over here. I enjoy digesting
是的。因为我就是这么想的。写第一集。是的。那压力太大了。那样的话，我会僵住的。我记得。我记得当我们被续订后回来，我们要拍摄这额外的五集时，我们有五个完整的剧本，然后他们决定拍哪一集。如果不是每周播出，他们会在开始这一季之前集体完成，我想这减轻了一些压力。确实会。是的。我还有一个速览。好的。你做你的速览吧，因为我有一些美味的笔记卡等着你。好的。我这边有一些金赛小贴士。我喜欢消化
your note cards. Digest this first though. What people, a lot of people want to know where did the idea for this episode come from. This episode is based on the real life experience of our writer's assistant, Tom. So when they were in that writer's room, they throw out ideas for episodes and Tom told this story about how when he was in college, he took a class and in the class, they did this exercise where they had to put note cards on their heads that said different ethnicities and then they had to go around and regard one another as that ethnicity using stereotypes. Where did he go to school? Oh my gosh. I don't know. Holy, holy. But that happened. Okay. So let that sink in. Yeah. That happened
你的笔记卡。不过先消化这个。很多人想知道这一集的想法是从哪里来的。这一集是基于我们编剧助理汤姆的真实生活经历。所以当他们在编剧室时，他们会提出剧集的想法，汤姆讲了这个故事，说他在大学时上了一门课，在课上，他们做了一个练习，必须把写着不同种族的小卡片贴在头上，然后他们必须四处走动，用刻板印象将彼此视为那个种族。他去哪上学？天哪。我不知道。天哪，天哪。但这确实发生了。好吧。所以让它沉淀一下。是的。这确实发生在
to people. That happened. Well, here's the thing I feel like about the show. And listen, you guys watch it, you know, there's a lot that happens that you're like, Oh yeah, something like that kind of happened at my job. And yeah, I mean, we had, I worked, when I worked at 1-800 Dennis, we had to go to these human resource, like, like resources meetings and they would act out skits for us about inappropriate behavior. Well, you know what, remember we used to have to sit through those sexual harassment seminars on the office. Yeah. The whole cast and crew would gather in the warehouse and once a year we had to get NBC made us do it. Yeah, made us do sexual harassment training. And then we signed papers saying we'd all
人们身上。这确实发生了。好吧，这就是我觉得关于这部剧的地方。听着，你们看它，你们知道，发生了很多事情，你会觉得，哦，是的，类似的事情在我的工作中也发生过。是的，我的意思是，我工作时，当我在1-800 Dennis工作时，我们必须参加这些人力资源会议，他们会为我们表演关于不当行为的小品。好吧，你知道吗，记得我们以前必须坐在《办公室》里参加性骚扰研讨会吗？是的。全体演职人员都会聚集在仓库里，每年一次，NBC强迫我们这样做。是的，强迫我们进行性骚扰培训。然后我们签署文件，说我们都会
behave appropriately. Correct. But do you remember what happened like in season four or five? The video package that they showed us was our show was what not to do. Yes. We're clips from the office. Yeah. We were sitting there watching clips of our show as examples of ways not to behave in a workplace. I've had actually a lot of people tell me that that it comes up in different ways that in their either college or work that our show is like what not to do. All right, I've got one more fast fact. And I also have a fan question. Well, okay, good. Cause then I have some Kinsey tidbits. Very good. What would you like first, the fast fact or the fan question? Jenna, what is happening? Are you going out
表现得体。没错。但你还记得第四季或第五季发生了什么吗？他们给我们看的视频片段就是我们的节目，告诉我们什么不该做。是的。是《办公室》的片段。是的。我们坐在那里看着我们节目的片段，作为职场中不当行为的例子。实际上很多人告诉我，在他们的大学或工作中，我们的节目被当作“什么不该做”的教材。好的，我还有一个速览。我还有一个粉丝提问。好吧，好的。因为我有一些金赛小贴士。很好。你先想要什么，速览还是粉丝提问？珍娜，怎么了？你要
of order? Who are you? You're right. What am I saying? I want the fast fact. Of course. Finish fast facts. And then go to fan questions. I'm sorry. I feeling very loosey goosey today, obviously. All right. Final fast fact. In this episode, we introduced two new characters. Yes, we do. Toby Flenderson and Kelly Kapoor played by two more members of our writing staff, Paul Lieberstein and Mindy Kaling. Yes, I do have to say I love the name Toby Flenderson. I love when a character's name sort of describes the character, but like the name Toby Flenderson, like when you see Paul on screen as Toby, you're like, Oh, of course that's Toby Flenderson. That's who that is. Absolutely. Perfect. A lot of people
不按顺序来吗？你是谁？你说得对。我在说什么？我想要速览。当然。完成速览。然后进入粉丝提问。抱歉。我今天感觉非常随意，显然。好的。最后一个速览。在这一集中，我们介绍了两个新角色。是的，我们介绍了。托比·弗兰德森和凯莉·卡普尔，由我们编剧团队的另外两名成员保罗·利伯斯坦和敏迪·卡灵饰演。是的，我不得不说我喜欢托比·弗兰德森这个名字。我喜欢当角色的名字能描述角色本身的时候，就像托比·弗兰德森这个名字，当你看到保罗在屏幕上饰演托比时，你会想，哦，当然那是托比·弗兰德森。就是那个人。绝对。完美。很多人
ask why were so many writers, actors on the show? And that was Greg Daniels. Greg believed that it would be a good idea for writers to have the experience of acting because it would give them a deeper appreciation of what an actor does, which I have to say is so brilliant. And I think there are a lot of directors that I know go take acting classes just so they can better speak to actors and understand actors. And it completely worked on our show that the writers were immersed with us because they really got to not just understand our jobs, but they got to see us being our characters firsthand. They got to see our little improvisations that they would never see if they were just stuck up in the writer's room. And all of
问为什么节目里有这么多编剧演员？那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格认为让编剧有表演经验是个好主意，因为这会让他们更深刻地理解演员的工作，我不得不说这太天才了。而且我认为我知道很多导演去上表演课，只是为了能更好地与演员沟通和理解演员。这在我们的节目中完全奏效了，编剧们与我们沉浸在一起，因为他们不仅真正理解了我们的工作，还亲眼看到了我们扮演角色的样子。他们看到了我们的小即兴表演，如果他们只是被困在编剧室里，他们永远也看不到。而所有
that ended up becoming a part of the show. I think it was so great. It really made us a cohesive show between the two departments, sort of the writers, the actors, this creative partnership. It always felt like a partnership to me and made me feel safe. Like I could try things, you know? Yes. But, you know, BJ and Mindy were really great performers. They were crossovers. But Paul was not a performer. Paul had only just been a writer. So I know this was like a huge sort of like step out of his comfort zone. And I think he thought it was going to be just this one little line in this episode. Right. Well, Jenna texted him this morning. I did. It was like, Paul, tell us the dish on how you became Toby.
这些最终都成为了节目的一部分。我觉得这太棒了。它确实使我们成为两个部门之间一个有凝聚力的节目，某种程度上是编剧、演员，这种创造性的伙伴关系。对我来说，这感觉总是一种伙伴关系，让我感到安全。就像我可以尝试一些事情，你知道吗？是的。但是，你知道，BJ和敏迪是非常出色的表演者。他们是跨界者。但保罗不是表演者。保罗一直只是个编剧。所以我知道这对他来说是一个巨大的走出舒适区的步骤。而且我想他以为这在这一集中只是这一句小台词。没错。好吧，珍娜今天早上给他发了短信。我发了。就像，保罗，告诉我们你是怎么成为托比的内幕。
And he just said, Greg kind of made me do it. He said he remembered walking in one day and it had been decided that he was going to play this role of Toby. And he really thought it was just going to be this one line. Right. He didn't think he was going to be a series regular. No. He did not think it was going to grow into what it was. But Kevin Riley, who was the head of NBC at the time, saw this episode. He loved it. He loved the dynamic between Michael Scott and Toby Flenderson. And he said, I want more of that. I want more Toby. And so then Paul officially became an actor on the show. Paul was not a performer and who was kind of a quiet person in real life. All of a sudden became a full-time
他只是说，格雷格强迫我这么做。他说他记得有一天走进去，决定让他扮演托比这个角色。他真的以为这只是一句台词。没错。他没想到他会成为常规演员。不。他没想到它会发展成现在的样子。但当时NBC的负责人凯文·赖利看了这一集。他很喜欢。他喜欢迈克尔·斯科特和托比·弗兰德森之间的互动。他说，我想要更多这样的内容。我想要更多托比。于是保罗正式成为了节目中的演员。保罗不是表演者，在现实生活中也是个安静的人。突然之间变成了一个全职
actor and writer. I think something we have to talk about too is the transformation of Kelly Kapoor. A lot of fans wrote in asking about this. And I'm sure you've got a note card about it, Angela. I do. First of all, all my note cards today are green and Jenna has already said they're hourish. But whatever, Jenna. So I have a note card that's just written Kelly's outfit. Yeah. Exclamation point because this is hilarious. Anyone that knows Mindy knows that after this episode, she was like, yeah, I'm not going to dress like that. Okay. Because she had on this like sort of paisley blouse and those that went all the way up to her neck. I know. And her hair up in like an updo and it was just so
演员和编剧。我想我们也必须谈谈凯莉·卡普尔的转变。很多粉丝写信询问这件事。我相信你有一张关于它的笔记卡，安吉拉。我有。首先，我今天所有的笔记卡都是绿色的，珍娜已经说过它们是“小时”的。但不管怎样，珍娜。所以我有一张笔记卡上只写着“凯莉的服装”。是的，感叹号，因为这太搞笑了。任何认识敏迪的人都知道，在这一集之后，她就说，是的，我不会那样穿。好吧。因为她穿了一件那种佩斯利花纹的衬衫，一直扣到脖子。我知道。她的头发盘起来，这对我来说太
funny to me. Very fussy. Very fussy and sort of like, just like buttoned up. And right after like this episode, I feel like she was like, yeah, I'm going to come in for a real wardrobe fitting and we're going to change up the way Kelly Kapoor looks. I think when she realized same as Paul that this was going to be more than just a one-off that she would be appearing regularly on the show. Not only did her wardrobe change, but the whole conceit of her character changed. And she started writing herself more into the character, the love of Beyonce and, you know, the clothes and the fashion show, fashion show, fashion show at lunch. And that's all Mindy. The romance with BJ. Yes. Exactly. Correct. All of those
搞笑了。非常挑剔。非常挑剔，而且有点，就像扣得严严实实的。就在这一集之后，我觉得她就像，是的，我要去进行真正的服装试穿，我们要改变凯莉·卡普尔的样子。我想当她意识到和保罗一样，这不仅仅是一次性的，她会定期出现在节目中时。不仅她的衣橱变了，她角色的整个构思也变了。她开始把自己更多地写进角色里，对碧昂丝的热爱，你知道，衣服和时装秀，午餐时的时装秀，时装秀，时装秀。那全是敏迪。与BJ的浪漫史。是的。没错。所有这些
elements sort of weaved their way into the show. But it is true in this first incarnation of Kelly Kapoor, she is very different. Not the Kelly we eventually learned to love. And I love the Kelly she became though, because she was so fun and just added so much like sort of like just sunshine to like whatever scene she was in. I don't know how to say it, but like there was always, she was just all so bubbly and everything and everyone else was so drab. So I thought she added much needed energy. She added literal color. Yeah, she was the only person who dressed literally colorfully. So do you want my fan question? Do I? Okay. Heather from Twitter asked. Hi, Heather. Hi, Heather. Heather asked, since
元素都融入了节目中。但确实在凯莉·卡普尔的第一个化身中，她非常不同。不是我们最终学会去爱的那个凯莉。但我喜欢她后来变成的那个凯莉，因为她太有趣了，给无论她在哪个场景中都增添了这么多阳光。我不知道怎么说，但就像总是，她总是那么活泼，而其他人却那么沉闷。所以我认为她增添了急需的活力。她增添了字面意义上的色彩。是的，她是唯一一个穿得色彩鲜艳的人。那么你想要我的粉丝提问吗？我想要吗？好的。推特上的希瑟问。嗨，希瑟。嗨，希瑟。希瑟问，因为
it was only the second episode, what was the atmosphere on set like filming? And I thought that was a really good question because we shot diversity day about six months after we shot the pilot. We took this really long break because we were waiting to find out if we were going to get picked up or not. And it was so thrilling to be reunited again. I remember when we were watching diversity day, people have asked me, when did you feel like you had a hit? And I said, it's the moment we were all in the room and we all had those note cards taped to our foreheads. And I was just looking around at all of us and Steve was being Michael and he was being so hilarious. And I thought, Oh my God, if any, if we can
这只是第二集，拍摄时的片场氛围如何？我觉得这是一个很好的问题，因为我们在拍摄试播集六个月后拍摄了《多元化日》。我们休息了很长一段时间，因为我们在等看是否会被续订。能再次重聚真是太激动人心了。我记得当我们重温《多元化日》时，人们问我，你什么时候觉得你成功了？我说，就是我们都在房间里，额头上都贴着那些笔记卡的那一刻。我环顾四周，史蒂夫在扮演迈克尔，他太搞笑了。我想，哦天哪，如果任何，如果我们能
just get anyone to watch the show, we're going to be hit. If anyone sees it, it's so good. And it really was in that moment. I was like, Oh wow, this is, this is lightning in a bottle. Now how do we get the world to watch it? Oh, I love that, Ange. Listen, should we take a break? Yeah, let's take a break. I have lots of note cards. Well, perfect. When we come back, we will really break down diversity day and get into the scenes and tell you all our stories. You say diversity. I say diversity. What? Yeah, it's just been bugging me. But anyway, diversity. Okay, let's go to a break. And we're back. Hello. All right. So the diversity day episode starts with Michael
只要有人看这个节目，我们就会成功。如果有人看到它，它太棒了。那一刻确实是这样。我就想，哦哇，这是，这是瓶中闪电。现在我们如何让全世界看它？哦，我喜欢那个，安吉。听着，我们要休息一下吗？是的，休息一下吧。我有很多笔记卡。好吧，完美。当我们回来时，我们将真正剖析《多元化日》，深入场景并告诉你们我们所有的故事。你说多元化。我说多元化。什么？是的，它一直困扰着我。但不管怎样，多元化。好的，我们去休息一下。我们回来了。你好。好的。所以《多元化日》这一集开始于迈克尔
explaining that today the office is having a mandatory diversity training. Yes. We also learned that today is the day that Jim is going to make his biggest sale of the year. He explains he only has to make one phone call and it amounts to 25% of his total sales for the year. But Dwight keeps making it impossible for him to make that call. And so the first way that Dwight makes it impossible for him to make this phone call is that he must shred paper at his desk. Oh, Dwight. Which I always thought was funny because you know, Pam has that industrial size shredder behind her desk. Pam has a shredder like the size of a Xerox machine behind her desk. Which we never use. Never use. Ever. I never shredded a single thing in it. And it used to get in the
解释说今天办公室要进行强制性的多元化培训。是的。我们还了解到今天是吉姆一年中最大的一笔销售的日子。他解释说他只需要打一个电话，就占了他全年总销售额的25%。但德怀特一直让他无法打那个电话。所以德怀特让他无法打这个电话的第一个方法是，他必须在办公桌上碎纸。哦，德怀特。我一直觉得这很有趣，因为你知道，帕姆的办公桌后面有那个工业级的碎纸机。帕姆的办公桌后面有一个像施乐复印机那么大的碎纸机。我们从来不用。从来不用。一次也没用过。我从来没在里面碎过任何东西。而且它过去常常挡在
way when the camera and it was a big argument over whether or not they could move it like the integrity of the documentary crew. Would they have moved the industrial shredder or not? No. And so I remember a day we were on set and they wanted to get this shot behind my desk and they said, if we could just move the shredder, we could get the shot you're asking for. And it was like a 30 minute argument over whether or not they could move or not move the shredder. Right. Because they didn't want to like ruin the integrity of the documentary look. Yes. This was a big thing all the time. They decided, you know, you can't move walls, you can't move windows, you can't move furniture. They did agree you could move this one plant
摄像机前面，关于是否可以移动它，纪录片摄制组的完整性问题，曾有过一场大争论。他们会移动工业碎纸机吗？不会。所以我记得有一天我们在片场，他们想在我的办公桌后面拍这个镜头，他们说，如果我们能移动碎纸机，我们就能拍到你要求的镜头。关于是否可以移动碎纸机，争论了30分钟。没错。因为他们不想破坏纪录片风格的完整性。是的。这一直是个大问题。他们决定，你知道，你不能移动墙壁，你不能移动窗户，你不能移动家具。他们确实同意你可以移动这棵植物
around. Also, they clearly agreed that you could move that conference table out and put chairs and then all of a sudden the conference table would be back. Where did the conference table go? I know. I've had so many people write to me like on social media be like, what happened with the conference table? It was there and then it's gone. Where does the conference table go? And I told them I said, you know what I would have loved at the end of one episode. All it would take is one episode and the whole nine seasons, if at the end credits, it just showed like Kevin and like Jim breaking down the conference table and Dwight and like stacking it in some storage thing and then having to go get it and put it back together.
四处走动。此外，他们显然同意你可以把会议桌搬走，放上椅子，然后突然之间会议桌又回来了。会议桌去哪了？我知道。很多人在社交媒体上写信问我，会议桌怎么了？它在那儿，然后又不见了。会议桌去哪了？我告诉他们，我说，你知道吗，我会在某一集的结尾加上这个。只需要一集，九季里只要一集，如果片尾字幕显示凯文和吉姆拆解会议桌，德怀特把它堆在某个储藏室里，然后不得不去把它拿回来重新组装。
But just as the credits rolled. Yes. I would love to see them carrying the conference table down to the warehouse or something. Like in pieces. Because where is it? I don't know. There is nowhere for it to be. I don't know. That is one of the great mysteries of the show. Where is the conference table? Every time Michael was like, conference room meeting that they were like, uh, because they knew they had to break down that table. Okay. Okay. Well, do you remember that shredding scene where Rain is shredding the paper? Yes. And so he's shredding paper, he's shredding paper. So then Rain notices that there's a special slot on his personal shredder for a credit card and he kind of stopped the filming and he said,
但就在字幕滚动的时候。是的。我很想看到他们把会议桌搬到仓库或其他地方。就像碎片一样。因为它在哪？我不知道。它没地方可去。我不知道。这是该剧的一大谜团。会议桌在哪？每次迈克尔说“会议室开会”，他们就想，呃，因为他们知道他们必须拆掉那张桌子。好的。好的。好吧，你还记得雷恩碎纸的那场戏吗？是的。所以他在碎纸，他在碎纸。然后雷恩注意到他的个人碎纸机上有一个专门放信用卡的插槽，他有点停止了拍摄，他说，
guys, I think I should shred a credit card. And we were thinking, well, okay. And he said, no, there's a special slot for it. I know. Everyone was like, is it going to work? And so he did it. He did it. They got him like a fake, like credit card kind of thing, the props department. And he did it, but it almost broke that shredder. It started going like, I remember sitting there and thinking, is it, you know, is it, what's happening? What's happening? But he was so determined. I also think Rain is like a gadget person a little bit. So he was like, Oh, there's a thing on here. I need to do it. Yeah. I need to work this part of the machine. I need to do it. Angela, would you like to do a card? I would, Jenna Fisher.
伙计们，我觉得我应该碎一张信用卡。我们当时想，好吧，好吧。他说，不，上面有一个专门的插槽。我知道。每个人都在想，它会起作用吗？所以他做了。他做了。道具组给了他一张假的信用卡之类的东西。他做了，但它差点弄坏了那个碎纸机。它开始发出那种声音，我记得坐在那里想，它，你知道，它，发生了什么？发生了什么？但他太坚决了。我也觉得雷恩有点像个小玩意儿爱好者。所以他就像，哦，这里有个东西。我需要做。是的。我需要操作机器的这一部分。我需要做。安吉拉，你想要一张卡片吗？我想要，珍娜·费舍。
Okay. So this card applies to the opening shot of the whole episode. There is a great establishing shot of the Homer Simpson doll. The camera is going past Phyllis's desk and it's sitting right there. And you know, it just makes me smile because I know that Greg Daniels wrote on the Simpsons. And this was his little nod to like the first part of his career, right? Yes. And it sat there all nine years. It did. That Simpson doll. So I love that. That's just like kind of a dorky moment. You guys know I love the things in the background. Well, you know what he did for the main cast. I'm sorry. I do know this. You do know. Are you saying I'm sorry because I didn't get one? Yeah. Because you're calling me not main cast? Well, we called you supporting cast. Is this as a gift?
好的。所以这张卡片适用于整集的开场镜头。有一个很棒的荷马·辛普森玩偶的建立镜头。摄像机经过菲利斯的办公桌，它就坐在那里。你知道，这只是让我微笑，因为我知道格雷格·丹尼尔斯在《辛普森一家》写过剧本。这是他对职业生涯第一部分的致敬，对吧？是的。它在那里坐了整整九年。确实。那个辛普森玩偶。所以我喜欢那个。这就像是一个书呆子时刻。你们知道我喜欢背景里的东西。好吧，你知道他为主要演员做了什么吗？抱歉。我知道这个。你知道。你是说我不是主要演员吗？好吧，我们称你为配角。这是作为礼物吗？
You guys, the rest of us didn't become series regular till booze cruise. That's story for later. But in the beginning, there were just five of us. Well, there weren't just the five of you, but you were the five that were the quote series regulars. That's right. There were just the five series regulars, I should say. And the rest of us were just trash in the corner. No, but we had to do a lot of extra stuff. You had to do press and whatnot. We had to do press and we had to do these crazy photo shoots and we did all this stuff as the show was launching. Listen, there is no debating. You guys were the core main cast and the rest of us filled out the picture. And then it grew and then the cast grew and then we had all of these series regulars.
伙计们，我们其他人直到“酒水巡游”才成为常规演员。那是后话。但起初，只有我们五个。好吧，不仅仅是你们五个，但你们是所谓的“常规演员”。没错。只有五个常规演员，我应该说。而我们其他人只是角落里的垃圾。不，但我们必须做很多额外的事情。你必须做媒体宣传之类的。我们必须做媒体宣传，我们必须做这些疯狂的照片拍摄，我们在节目推出时做了所有这些事情。听着，毫无争议。你们是核心主要演员，而我们其他人填补了画面。然后它成长了，然后演员阵容扩大了，然后我们有了所有这些常规演员。
But I'm going to give you a little and you can leave that in, Sam. I'm going to give you a little shiitake sometimes. All right, listen. So as a gift, Greg had the illustrators over at the Simpsons turn us all into Simpson characters. And it was me, John, Rain and Steve huddled around a computer. Now that I'm saying it, I realize I think BJ Novak was left out of this photo. Sorry, BJ. But we were Simpsonized and he gave us these illustrations in like a frame. It's really cool. It's really cool. It's in my living room. It's like a treasured item from the show. Jenna is a Simpson. I have a Simpson version of me. All right. I want to talk about Pam's free cell and so does BNG Chris on Twitter. Well, let's hear it. BNG Chris.
但我会给你一点，你可以把它留在里面，萨姆。我会给你一点香菇。好的，听着。作为礼物，格雷格让《辛普森一家》的插画师把我们都变成了辛普森角色。是我、约翰、雷恩和史蒂夫挤在电脑前。现在我这么说，我意识到我想BJ·诺瓦克被排除在这张照片之外了。抱歉，BJ。但我们被“辛普森化”了，他把这些插画装在相框里送给了我们。真的很酷。真的很酷。它在我的客厅里。这是节目中珍贵的物品。珍娜是一个辛普森人。我有一个辛普森版本的我。好的，我想谈谈帕姆的空当接龙，推特上的BNG Chris也想谈。好吧，让我们听听。BNG Chris。
All right. He asked if we were actually good at free cell. And the answer is oh, yes, we were. You want to know why? This is one of my note cards too. We didn't get Wi-Fi until July of 2006. And it was such a big deal on our set that a memo went around and I saved the memo. It was because to give you some context, we shot this episode in 2004. Yes. And so it wasn't until 2006 that we got internet. So for the pilot, they were nothing. They were literally like pieces of plastic. I have to tell you something, Angela. My computer on the pilot was real. Son of a bitch, Jenna. I'm so sorry. Main cast got real computers. Shut up. Are you serious? You and John and Rain had actual computers with no internet, but you had games for the pilot?
好的。他问我们是否真的擅长空当接龙。答案是，哦，是的，我们很擅长。你想知道为什么吗？这也是我的笔记卡之一。直到2006年7月我们才有Wi-Fi。这在我们的片场是一件大事，甚至传阅了一份备忘录，我保存了那份备忘录。这是因为为了给你一些背景，我们在2004年拍摄了这一集。是的。所以直到2006年我们才有互联网。所以对于试播集，它们什么都不是。它们简直就像塑料片。我必须告诉你一件事，安吉拉。我在试播集上的电脑是真的。该死的，珍娜。我很抱歉。主要演员有真正的电脑。闭嘴。你是认真的吗？你、约翰和雷恩有真正的电脑，没有互联网，但你们有游戏？
Yeah. Will this ever end? Will it ever end? All these things I'm learning. Well, back in accounting, guys, we had a piece of plastic that they made look like a computer. You just had to stare at a plastic box. Piece of plastic that did nothing. So we passed notes. We passed a bunch of notes. I haven't known when to tell you this because you've told the story before that our computer. And you have said silence. I haven't known how to tell you that all along I had a real computer. Oh my God. What else is going to come out in this podcast? I don't know. Holy crap. Well, we passed a lot of notes and I saved those two. Oscar can draw. He's a really good drawer and he would draw me and Brian as Kevin and Angela. And I saved them all. So there, Jenna.
是的。这会结束吗？它会结束吗？所有这些我正在学习的事情。好吧，在会计部，伙计们，我们有一块塑料，他们让它看起来像电脑。你只能盯着一个塑料盒。什么都没做的塑料片。所以我们传纸条。我们传了很多纸条。我一直不知道什么时候告诉你这件事，因为你之前讲过我们的电脑的故事。而且你说过沉默。我一直不知道怎么告诉你，我一直有一台真正的电脑。哦，天哪。这个播客里还会爆出什么？我不知道。天哪。好吧，我们传了很多纸条，我也把那些保存下来了。奥斯卡会画画。他画画很好，他会画我和布莱恩，作为凯文和安吉拉。我把它们都保存下来了。所以，珍娜。
That's what you were doing while I was on my actual computer. Well, whatever. The answer to that story is yes. We were very good at Solitaire because it's all we had to do for like two years. It's true. And we had on set free cell competitions and we would compete with the casting crew. In between scenes, the crew would sit down at a desk and they would play free cell. And Kate Flannery held the title for a very long time. She was really very good. Phyllis was also very good. Kate is so good though. Yes. With the free cell, the competition was who could do it in the fewest moves. And yeah, Kate was really good. I never made the top 10. I would also lose patience. Okay. All right. Get going. What else you got over there, Fisher? What else are you hiding from me
这就是当我在我的真实电脑上时你在做的事。好吧，不管怎样。那个故事的答案是，是的。我们非常擅长纸牌游戏，因为这是我们两年来唯一能做的事。这是真的。我们在片场举行空当接龙比赛，我们会和演职人员竞争。在场景之间，工作人员会坐在桌子旁，他们会玩空当接龙。凯特·弗兰纳里保持了很长时间的冠军头衔。她真的很擅长。菲利斯也非常擅长。不过凯特真的很棒。是的。对于空当接龙，比赛是谁能用最少的步数完成。是的，凯特真的很棒。我从来没进过前10名。我也会失去耐心。好的。好的。继续。你那边还有什么，费舍？你还对我隐瞒了什么
that you're not telling me? What other perks did you have? Well, this wasn't really a perk, but this was a little sneaky. So during this episode, off camera, there was a whole thing going on and it involved me and Phyllis. So Phyllis and I are from St. Louis, Missouri. And during this time, the Cardinals were in the playoffs. I remember this. They ended up in the World Series against the Boston Red Sox. And in between scenes, Phyllis and I would sneak back to my trailer and watch the Cardinals games. Yes. And we were rooting hard for the Cardinals. And it was very difficult for us because basically everyone else on the set was from Boston. Steve, BJ, John, more people. Everyone was rooting for the Red Sox, except for me and Phyllis. And I'm really rooting for the
你没告诉我的？你还有什么其他福利？好吧，这不算真正的福利，但这有点鬼鬼祟祟。所以在这集拍摄期间，在镜头外，发生了一整件事，涉及我和菲利斯。所以菲利斯和我来自密苏里州圣路易斯。在这段时间里，红雀队在季后赛中。我记得这个。他们最终在世界大赛中对阵波士顿红袜队。在场景之间，菲利斯和我溜回我的拖车看红雀队的比赛。是的。我们非常支持红雀队。这对我们来说非常困难，因为基本上片场的所有其他人都是来自波士顿。史蒂夫、BJ、约翰，更多人。每个人都在支持红袜队，除了我和菲利斯。我真的在和你一起支持
Cardinals with you. Do you remember that? You don't remember that? No. You and I are going to have a talk after this, lady. Well, I did. You brought me onto your side. Listen, one of the things I remember so distinctly about that World Series is that at the end of work, we would stay and we would all go into John's trailer and we would watch the game. Angela, if you were in John's trailer, you were rooting for Boston. Phyllis and I watched it in my trailer. Wait, I didn't know that. Wait, you weren't. Oh, right. You didn't go in John. No. Oh. We were in Ireland, Phyllis and I. We were in Ireland. Well, John's trailer was really fun. A lot of people were in there. Of course, they were. I think I probably stopped by your trailer and was like... A little sad in here.
红雀队。你记得吗？你不记得了吗？不。你和我之后要谈谈，女士。好吧，我记得。你把我拉到了你这边。听着，关于那届世界大赛，我记得最清楚的一件事是，工作结束后，我们会留下来，我们都会去约翰的拖车里看比赛。安吉拉，如果你在约翰的拖车里，你就是在支持波士顿。菲利斯和我在我的拖车里看。等等，我不知道。等等，你没有。哦，对了。你没去约翰那里。不。哦。我们在爱尔兰，菲利斯和我。我们在爱尔兰。好吧，约翰的拖车真的很有趣。很多人都在里面。当然，他们都在。我想我可能顺便去了你的拖车，然后……这里有点悲伤。
And I went into the party trailer where everyone was gathered. Well, also, Boston swept the series four to zero. So it was a particularly depressing room. I remember there being snacks and like laughter. Phyllis and I were just in my trailer crying. Okay, maybe I didn't realize that. No big deal. Okay. All right, we should really get back to the meat of this episode. Oh my God, you guys, I'm sorry. We've gone on so many tangents. This is what happens when we get together. Okay, back to diversity day. All right. So Mr. Brown comes into the office to run the diversity training and once again, played by one of the members of the writing staff. So brilliant. Larry Willmar. Larry Willmar. So smart. So funny. He originally read the part during a table read. Yes. Just
然后我去了大家聚集的派对拖车。好吧，而且，波士顿以四比零横扫了系列赛。所以那是一个特别令人沮丧的房间。我记得那里有零食和笑声。菲利斯和我在我的拖车里哭。好吧，也许我没意识到这一点。没关系。好的。好吧，我们真的应该回到这一集的重点了。哦，天哪，伙计们，我很抱歉。我们跑题太多了。这就是我们聚在一起时会发生的事情。好的，回到《多元化日》。好的。所以布朗先生来到办公室进行多元化培训，再次由编剧团队的一名成员扮演。太天才了。拉里·威尔莫。拉里·威尔莫。太聪明了。太搞笑了。他最初在剧本朗读时读了这个角色。是的。只是
because they hadn't cast the role yet. They were going to cast the role. They just hadn't gotten to it yet. That's right. Greg loved how he read it so much that he asked Larry to audition because this was a big part. This wasn't just one line. So you had to audition for a role of the size. So they put him through the paces. Poor guy. But what I loved about his deliveries, it was so straight. He did it like so straight. He put nothing on it. No spin on it. And that's why it worked. But this was not the first time that Larry Willmar has performed. He was a writer performer. Yes. Did you know he had a recurring role on the facts of life? No. Yeah. As a police officer. Somebody did a deep dive on the internet. I did. Want to hear what else the internet told
因为他们还没选定这个角色。他们打算选角。他们只是还没到那一步。没错。格雷格非常喜欢他的朗读方式，以至于他要求拉里试镜，因为这是一个大角色。这不仅仅是一句台词。所以你必须为这个规模的角色试镜。所以他们让他经历了考验。可怜的家伙。但我喜欢他的表演方式，它太直白了。他演得太直白了。他没加任何东西。没加任何修饰。这就是它奏效的原因。但这并不是拉里·威尔莫第一次表演。他是一位编剧兼表演者。是的。你知道他在《生活的事实》中有一个常驻角色吗？不。是的。饰演一名警察。有人在互联网上进行了深入挖掘。我做了。想听听互联网还告诉了我什么
me? Yeah. He created the Bernie Mac show for which he won an Emmy. And he was a daily show correspondent. He's very funny. And I actually emailed him and he wants to come on and chat with us. So. Oh, yes. I know. I know. He couldn't do it for this episode, but we're going to get Larry on. I'm so excited. We should because I want to get more of that story of exactly how he wound up as Mr. Brown and what it was like for him to do those scenes with Steve. Oh, was Steve just like, he was just messing with him all day. And he was stayed so stoic. I know. He was amazing. I have to say this one story about Larry Willmar. When this show was going to air, he invited the whole cast over to watch it at his house. And I had like an apartment at that time. So like anyone that had
吗？是的。他创作了《伯尼·麦克秀》，并因此获得了艾美奖。他还是《每日秀》的记者。他非常有趣。我实际上给他发了电子邮件，他想来和我们聊天。所以。哦，是的。我知道。我知道。他没能参加这一集，但我们会请拉里来的。我太兴奋了。我们应该请他，因为我想了解更多关于他究竟是如何成为布朗先生的故事，以及他和史蒂夫演那些戏是什么感觉。哦，史蒂夫是不是整天都在捉弄他？而他一直保持着冷静。我知道。他太棒了。我必须讲一个关于拉里·威尔莫的故事。当这个节目要播出时，他邀请了全体演员去他家看。我当时有套公寓。所以任何有
a house, I was like, Oh my God, you're like the real deal. Yes. You're an adult. You're an adult. Well, that's something we used to do. We used to watch every week together as a cast, these viewing parties. I hosted everybody for the pilot. It was before it aired. Greg came over with a DVD of the pilot and the cast piled into my living room. We couldn't figure out how to make it work at first. Do you remember like your sound wasn't like the DVD wasn't working. We were all freaking out. And we had, well, I also remember we had to like move furniture out of the way and people were on the floor. I have a picture of that. And there's Steve Carell just sitting on my floor. He didn't get a spot on the couch ready to watch the pilot. I have one just like that. And I remember
一个房子，我当时就想，天哪，你真是个正经人。是的。你是个成年人了。你是个成年人了。嗯，那是我们过去常做的事。我们过去每周都会作为演员聚在一起看剧，举办这种观看派对。试播集的时候是我招待大家的。那是在它播出之前。格雷格带着试播集的DVD过来，演员们都挤进了我的客厅。起初我们不知道怎么弄。你还记得吗，你的声音，或者说DVD没法播放。我们都快急疯了。而且我记得我们还得把家具搬开，大家就坐在地板上。我有一张那样的照片。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔就坐在我的地板上。他没抢到沙发上的位置，准备看试播集。我有一张一模一样的照片。我记得
telling everyone, okay, so my building doesn't have parking. So here I am telling the cast, you have to street park. Also, I'm the unit way in the back. It says eight to four, but I'm eight to four and a half. And everyone came. It was like so sweet. And Paul Feig used to host a lot. Oh my gosh. And Paul and Lori Feig, they would put out a fantastic little buffet. They would. They are great hosts. But yes, we used to watch the episodes together as a cast, which is something we did really for years. For years. Should we take a break? Yes, I think we take a break. And when we come back, Jenna, I have a question about something that's in the background. You know how I love things in the background. You've really been the
告诉大家，好吧，我的大楼没有停车位。所以我在这里告诉演员们，你们得停在街上。而且，我的单元在最里面。上面写着八点到四点，但我的是八点到四点半。大家都来了。真是太贴心了。保罗·费格过去经常做东。天哪。保罗和洛里·费格，他们会准备很棒的小自助餐。他们会的。他们是很好的主人。但没错，我们过去常作为演员一起看剧集，这是我们真正坚持了多年的事情。多年来。我们要休息一下吗？是的，我想我们该休息一下了。回来之后，珍娜，我有个关于背景里某样东西的问题。你知道我有多喜欢背景里的东西。你真的是这个播客的
background spotter of this podcast. I have. You guys, people will hear as you will hear because we've done a few of these. Jenna knows I love things in the background. And we're back. Hello everyone. Angela, give it to us. What's your observation? Well, I have two. First of all, at six minutes, around 46 seconds, I can make out the yellow post-it note sprinkles invite that I drew on the partition and Kevin's desk. Really? Yes. We talked about this in the pilot. It's a little yellow post-it note. And I can just see the side of it. And it just made me happy because it was there all nine years, as you know, all nine seasons. And then Brian gave it to me and I have it and I love it, but I can spot it. And that just made me happy. So there you go.
背景观察员。我是。你们这些家伙，大家会听到的，正如你们将听到的，因为我们已经做过几期了。珍娜知道我喜欢背景里的东西。我们回来了。大家好。安吉拉，告诉我们。你有什么发现？嗯，我有两个。首先，在6分46秒左右，我能辨认出我画在隔板和凯文桌子上的黄色便利贴Sprinkles邀请函。真的吗？是的。我们在试播集里谈过这个。那是一张黄色的小便利贴。我只能看到它的一侧。这让我很高兴，因为它在那里待了整整九年，如你所知，整整九季。后来布莱恩把它给了我，我留着它，我很喜欢，但我能认出它。这让我很高兴。所以，就是这样。
There you go. Sprinkles post-it note. And here's the second thing I observed at around eight minutes, 30 seconds. There is a cartoon taped to Michael's door with like a notepad with like some writing on it. Okay. That's all I got. What? What is the cartoon? I don't know. I did take a picture of my TV and I zoomed in as big as I could. I don't know what it is. That's it. That's it. Your observation is that there is a cartoon on Michael's door. The end. Okay. Well, the way you're looking at me is a little judgy. They're not all going to pay off. I mean, I thought you were going to tell me what it was or how it got there, but no. I don't know. But I bet someone else is looking at it and being like, Angela, I saw that too. I don't know. I don't know what it's about.
就是这样。Sprinkles便利贴。这是我观察到的第二件事，在大约8分30秒。迈克尔的门上贴着一张卡通画，旁边有个记事本，上面写着些字。好吧。我就这些发现。什么？那张卡通画是什么？我不知道。我确实拍了电视机的照片，还尽可能地放大了。我不知道那是什么。就是这样。就是这样。你的观察结果就是迈克尔的门上有一张卡通画。结束了。好吧，你看着我的眼神有点评判意味。并不是所有的观察都能有结果。我是说，我以为你会告诉我那是什么或者它是怎么在那里的，但并没有。我不知道。但我敢打赌别人也在看它，然后会说，安吉拉，我也看到了。我不知道。我不知道那是什么意思。
Thank you so much for that one. Moving on. I need to talk about a scene. Okay. That contains one of my favorite lines of all time from the show. I know it. I know it because it's one of mine. I know it. When Steve does his own diversity training, he makes a video. Yes. And in that video, he has a line where he says, Abraham Lincoln once said, if you are a racist, I will attack you with the north. I love that line so much. And I asked BJ who wrote that line because I know there's a collective element to the script writing. So the process is they break down the plot and then a single writer goes and writes it, but then they bring that script back to the group and people can pitch jokes. They do joke punch up. Yeah. They can do joke punch up.
非常感谢你的分享。继续。我需要谈谈一个场景。好的。它包含了剧中我最喜欢的台词之一。我知道是哪句。我知道，因为那也是我最喜欢的之一。我知道。当史蒂夫做他自己的多元化培训时，他制作了一个视频。是的。在那个视频里，他有一句台词说：“亚伯拉罕·林肯曾经说过，如果你是个种族主义者，我就会用北方来攻击你。”我太喜欢那句台词了。我问了BJ是谁写的，因为我知道剧本创作有一个集体参与的元素。所以流程是他们先拆解情节，然后由一位编剧去写，但之后他们会把剧本带回小组，大家可以提出笑话。他们会进行笑话润色。是的。他们可以进行笑话润色。
And BJ said it was Paul Lieberstein. Oh, so smart. And he said that the people in the writer's room thought it might be like too heady of a joke or that it might not really land, but not only did it land. It is one of the most quoted lines from the show and inspired a fan site called Northern Attack. Northern Attack. Yes. Which was great. So smart. So great. I also asked BJ about diversity today and diversity tomorrow. And he said that he wrote that, that he wrote diversity, that it was called diversity today. And then, you know, Michael calls it diversity tomorrow because today is almost over. But he said his original pitch, which he was very sad to have to lose, was that it was actually called diversity 360. And Michael said in his video that he was
BJ说是保罗·利伯斯坦写的。哦，太聪明了。他说编剧室里的人觉得这可能是一个太深奥的笑话，或者可能不会有什么效果，但它不仅奏效了。它是剧中被引用最多的台词之一，还启发了一个叫“北方攻击”的粉丝网站。北方攻击。是的。这太棒了。太聪明了。太棒了。我还问了BJ关于“今日多元化”和“明日多元化”的事。他说那是他写的，他写了多元化，它原本叫“今日多元化”。然后，你知道，迈克尔把它叫作“明日多元化”，因为今天快结束了。但他原本的提议，他很遗憾没能保留下来，是它其实应该叫“多元化360”。迈克尔在他的视频里说他来自
from diversity 365 because diversity should never take five days off. But unfortunately, there was a real diversity 360. And they couldn't clear it because it would have seemed like we were making fun of a real business. So he had to change it to diversity today, diversity tomorrow. That is so funny. I have a little note card here for you, lady. Give it to me. So there's a moment in the conference room where Jenna and I are seated next to each other. And oh, yeah. So we were rarely seated next to each other because we would just start laughing. This is what we discovered pretty early on. But this was an extreme reason why. This was an extreme reason why. So Steve, as Michael, like, you know, we knew he was going to sit into the scene, but we didn't know exactly how.
“多元化365”，因为多元化永远不应该休息五天。但不幸的是，现实中真的有一个叫“多元化360”的公司。他们无法通过审核，因为那看起来就像我们在嘲笑一家真实的企业。所以他不得不把它改成“今日多元化，明日多元化”。那太搞笑了。我这里有一张小卡片给你，女士。给我吧。在会议室里有一个时刻，我和珍娜坐在一起。哦，是的。我们很少坐在一起，因为我们一坐在一起就会开始大笑。这是我们很早就发现的。但这有一个极端的原因。这是一个极端的原因。所以史蒂夫，作为迈克尔，你知道，我们知道他会坐进那个场景，但我们不知道具体会怎么做。
Like he hadn't done this in any rehearsals. So here we are, the camera's rolling. And that conference room is small. And so he was right in front of Jenna and I. Yeah. And he turned, as Michael, he turns his chair around and straddles it. And it looks like an office chair that was very bouncy. Bouncy. Like it, like, bobbed up and down. And he kept bobbing forward and back, like, kind of, kind of. Very groiny. Kind of grinding into the chair a little bit, like, leaning forward. And Jenna and I were like, so, we were like, oh my God. Well, you can see my hand is up by my mouth through most of that scene. And it was because when I started to break, I would cover my mouth. It was so hard not to just laugh through the whole scene because
就像他在任何排练中都没做过一样。所以我们在这里，摄像机在转动。那个会议室很小。所以他就在我和珍娜面前。是的。他转过身，作为迈克尔，他把椅子转过来，跨坐在上面。那看起来像是一把非常有弹性的办公椅。有弹性。就像，上下起伏。他不停地前后晃动，有点，有点。非常猥琐。有点像在椅子上磨蹭，有点像向前倾。我和珍娜当时就想，天哪。嗯，你可以看到在那个场景的大部分时间里，我的手都放在嘴边。那是因为当我开始破功时，我会捂住嘴。太难了，不能在整个场景中一直笑，因为
he was, he was so brilliantly being this cringy boss who's so inappropriate, but is trying to do something good for the office, like all of his intentions, you know. That was the scene that I think I broke the most in for this episode. It was, it was that with him just like grinding into that chair. But you were making it worse because you were right next to me. And if you notice, for the rest of the episode, we are separated. We're separated. Also, I don't know if you noticed, but I try really hard not to look at you. Like, because I was like, I couldn't look at you, but I could see your shoulders shaking. Yeah. Or I could like sense you shaking. And then I would just start laughing. And I didn't want to laugh. I guess I was like, oh God,
他，他非常出色地扮演了这个令人尴尬的老板，他非常不合时宜，但又试图为办公室做点好事，就像他所有的意图一样，你知道。我认为这是我在这一集中破功最多的场景。就是那个，他就在那把椅子上磨蹭。但你让情况变得更糟了，因为你就坐在我旁边。如果你注意的话，在这一集的其余部分，我们被分开了。我们被分开了。另外，我不知道你有没有注意到，我非常努力地不看你。因为我当时想，我不能看你，但我能看到你的肩膀在颤抖。是的。或者我能感觉到你在颤抖。然后我就会开始大笑。我不想笑。我想我当时想，哦天哪，
I was still like every day, but like, please don't fire me. Please don't fire me. Please don't fire me. We're trying to be professionals. We're trying to be professionals. And Steve is so professional, but I want to challenge you guys if Steve Krill turned to chair around backwards and started kind of like leaning into it close to you. It was so close to us. It was very close. I feel like the scene itself doesn't properly communicate how close. No, it doesn't. Well, I did a little bit of background looking. Oh, and there is a reflection of us in the television screen when the shots are on Steve. And I think if you look really closely at the reflection, you can see me break one time. Oh my God. You and I have become like obsessed with our own show.
我还是像每天一样，但请不要解雇我。请不要解雇我。请不要解雇我。我们试图表现得专业。我们试图表现得专业。史蒂夫非常专业，但我向你们挑战，如果史蒂夫·卡瑞尔把椅子向后转，开始有点像靠在上面靠近你。离我们太近了。离我们非常近。我觉得场景本身并没有充分传达出有多近。不，没有。嗯，我做了一点背景调查。哦，当镜头对着史蒂夫时，电视屏幕上有我们的倒影。我想如果你仔细看那个倒影，你可以看到我破功了一次。天哪。你和我已经变得像沉迷于我们自己的节目一样了。
It's so ridiculous. It's a little odd. It's a little odd. Okay. I have a quick story about those note cards we had to tape to our foreheads. Oh, yes. Okay. So here's the thing, guys. Imagine taping a note card to your forehead because it had the double stick tape. So it would stay in place. Imagine putting that on at 730 in the morning and not taking it off to like five PM, which is what we did, which is what we did. I mean, we did take it off at lunch for 30 minutes, but then we had to put it back on. At the end of the day of wearing that double stick tape on my forehead, when we took that note card off, it had peeled off all my baby hairs on my forehead. Yes. And I had a strip, like a, like a bare strip on my forehead. And so the next morning,
这太荒谬了。这有点奇怪。这有点奇怪。好吧，我有一个关于我们必须贴在额头上的那些记事卡的小故事。哦，是的。好吧，事情是这样的，伙计们。想象一下把一张记事卡贴在额头上，因为它有双面胶。所以它会保持在原位。想象一下早上7点30分贴上它，直到下午5点才取下来，这就是我们所做的，这就是我们所做的。我的意思是，我们在午餐时确实取下来了30分钟，但之后我们不得不把它贴回去。在额头上贴了一整天双面胶后，当我们取下那张记事卡时，它把我额头上的所有细小绒毛都撕掉了。是的。我的额头上有一条，就像一条光秃秃的条纹。所以第二天早上，
when we went into hair and makeup, the makeup would not adhere to my forehead. It was like you had waxed your forehead in one tiny rectangle spot. Yes. And a few of us had that. A few of us like, I mean, I'm so fair that like my skin like shows everything, but I had kind of like this, like this rectangle hickey on my forehead of where that note card had been there all day. Well, I remember us walking around backstage, getting snacks, using the restroom. No, because then they'd have to, you know, it was a continuity thing. Even they didn't want it to be in any way different. Yeah. They took photos of us to make sure it was always in the exact same spot. It wasn't too high or too low. And once they taped it on, they were really like, guys, please don't
当我们去化妆间时，化妆品无法附着在我的额头上。就像你在额头上打了一块小小的长方形蜡一样。是的。我们中有几个人是这样的。我们中有几个人，我的意思是，我的皮肤太白了，所以什么都能看出来，但我额头上有一种，就像那种长方形的吻痕，那是记事卡贴了一整天的地方。嗯，我记得我们在后台走来走去，吃零食，上厕所。不，因为那样他们就得，你知道，这是一个连续性问题。即使他们也不希望它有任何不同。是的。他们给我们拍了照片，以确保它总是处在完全相同的位置。它不会太高或太低。一旦他们把它贴上，他们真的会说，伙计们，请不要
take your note card off your forehead. So imagine being like, Oh, we have a 15 minute break. I'm going to get some pretzels and a cheese stick, but I'm eating the cheese stick and pretzels while wearing, you know, a note card in my head that said Jamaica. That's how we walked around. Like we went to the bathroom. Yeah. Oh my Lord. A lot of people asked about the note cards. Like, was there, did we have any say in what our note card said? No. No, it was all scripted. It wasn't random. A lot of people asked questions about how much improvisation happened in the scenes with the note cards. All that was scripted. All scripted. Dwight saying, Oh man, am I a woman? That was scripted. There was even a deleted scene in there where Jim pranks Dwight after Dwight figures out
把记事卡从额头上取下来。所以想象一下，哦，我们有15分钟的休息时间。我要去拿些椒盐卷饼和奶酪条，但我一边吃奶酪条和椒盐卷饼，一边戴着，你知道，头上贴着一张写着“牙买加”的记事卡。我们就是那样走来走去的。就像我们去洗手间一样。是的。哦，天哪。很多人问关于记事卡的事。就像，有没有，我们对记事卡上写什么有发言权吗？没有。没有，全是剧本写的。不是随机的。很多人问关于记事卡场景中即兴表演有多少的问题。所有这些都是剧本写的。全是剧本。德怀特说，哦天哪，我是个女人吗？那是剧本写的。甚至还有一个删除的场景，吉姆在德怀特弄清楚
what his race is. Jim gives him a new card and he's like, here, here, you should have this new card and Dwight tapes it to his head and what Jim's written on it is Dwight. And so I remember filming scenes where he's walking around the room and we're all saying things like, Oh man, you're annoying. You're difficult to be around. Yeah. Yeah. And he's guessing all these different things. And then really it just says Dwight on his forehead. Okay. So I heard there was a deleted scene and guys, I bought the DVDs. Okay. I bought the DVDs at Target and, but I don't have a DVD player. This is your problem. You're very close to being able to enjoy this DVD. I know. You're one major step away. I forgot we didn't have a DVD player anymore. So I have them, but I read that
他的种族后捉弄他。吉姆给了他一张新卡片，他说，给你，给你，你应该有这张新卡片，德怀特把它贴在头上，吉姆在上面写的是“德怀特”。所以我记得拍摄了一些场景，他在房间里走来走去，我们都在说，哦天哪，你真烦人。你很难相处。是的。是的。他在猜所有这些不同的东西。然后实际上它只是在他的额头上写着“德怀特”。好吧。所以我听说有一个删除的场景，伙计们，我买了DVD。好的。我在塔吉特买了DVD，但我没有DVD播放机。这是你的问题。你离享受这张DVD只有一步之遥。我知道。你离成功只差一步。我忘了我们不再有DVD播放机了。所以我买了它们，但我读到
there was a deleted scene where Devin, Devin who sat in the background with Creed, has a note card on his forehead and you see it. I think he's outside and as Michael walks in, he's outside and his note card says West Nile. I don't know that. Is that true? I don't know. That's so funny. If you get a DVD player, will you come back and tell us? Yes. I've got to get to the bottom of that. I do want to talk about one scene because when I put it out on Twitter that we were recording this episode, the most frequently asked question was about the scene where Mindy slaps Steve. Oh yeah. People had a lot of questions about that scene and I remember filming that and the reason I remember filming it is because Mindy could not stop laughing. Mindy could not stop
有一个删除的场景，德文，那个和克里德坐在背景里的德文，他的额头上有一张记事卡，你可以看到。我想他在外面，当迈克尔走进来时，他在外面，他的记事卡上写着“西尼罗河”。我不知道那个。那是真的吗？我不知道。那太搞笑了。如果你买个DVD播放机，你会回来告诉我们吗？是的。我得查个水落石出。我确实想谈谈一个场景，因为当我在推特上发布我们要录制这一集时，最常被问到的问题是关于明迪扇史蒂夫耳光的场景。哦，是的。人们对那个场景有很多疑问，我记得拍摄那个场景，我记得拍摄它的原因是因为明迪无法停止大笑。明迪无法停止
laughing. She laughed every single take. Every take and we had, we were all standing there watching. Yes. And she, every time it was time for her to slap Steve, she would laugh. But then right after she slapped Steve, she would laugh. One thing we should say and a lot of people wondered was the slap real or fake. Well, I remember we shot that so many times and the majority of the time it was fake. It was fake. She made no contact with him because people wanted to know, oh my gosh, she'd have a big red mark on his face or anything like that. And no, she, and thank goodness it was fake because she kept breaking every time. It was like unusable. I feel like, I do remember Steve and I don't know if you remember this Jenna, I do feel like I remember him in one take saying,
大笑。她每一条都在笑。每一条，我们都站在那里看着。是的。而且她，每次轮到她扇史蒂夫耳光时，她就会笑。但就在她扇完史蒂夫之后，她又会笑。有一件事我们应该说，很多人想知道那个耳光是真的还是假的。嗯，我记得我们拍了很多次，大多数时候它是假的。它是假的。她没有和他有任何接触，因为人们想知道，天哪，他的脸上会有红印之类的吗？没有，她，谢天谢地它是假的，因为她每次都破功。这就像无法使用。我觉得，我确实记得史蒂夫，我不知道你是否记得，珍娜，我确实觉得我记得他在一条里说，
I think you, you know, just go ahead and hit me once. Yes. Go ahead and hit me one time. Right. So I think there was one where she made contact with him and there was also one time she didn't laugh and that's the time it's in the episode. That's it. That's it. But I think if you look really closely, you can see, I mean, we know Mindy. Yeah. I think we, I can see her, her eyes, her eyes a little bit. Or she does a thing where she doesn't close her mouth all the way and that's because she's about to laugh and she's trying not to. Here's the thing, we got to know each other all so well that I know everyone's tell before they break. Yes. Like it's just so like clear when someone's about to laugh.
我想你，你知道，就直接打我一下吧。是的。直接打我一下。对。所以我认为有一条她是和他有接触的，还有一次她没有笑，那就是出现在剧集里的那一条。就是这样。就是这样。但我想如果你仔细看，你可以看到，我的意思是，我们了解明迪。是的。我想我们，我能看到她，她的眼睛，她的眼睛有点。或者她做了一个动作，她没有完全闭上嘴，那是因为她快要笑了，她在努力忍住。事情是这样的，我们彼此非常了解，以至于我知道每个人破功前的信号。是的。就像当有人快要笑出来时，这非常明显。
Another thing more than one person asked, I guess there's a controversy. Is Steve saying cookie cookie or googie googie? He's saying googie googie. Googie googie. Yeah. Yes. Well, I'm glad we could solve that controversy. I have, I have some note cards, Milady. Let's do a note card. Okay. All right. This is a very sort of dorky actor moment. So just bear with me. But I thought John, as Jim did such a fantastic job on the phone with Mr. Decker when he loses his sale to Dwight. Oh, it is one of the hardest things in the world to have a fake one-sided phone conversation. That has hills and valleys of emotion. Yes. Or you're reacting, like this, he's excited, then he's disappointed, then he like figures out what happened.
还有一件事不止一个人问，我想有一个争议。史蒂夫是在说“cookie cookie”还是“googie googie”？他在说“googie googie”。“googie googie”。是的。是的。好吧，我很高兴我们能解决那个争议。我有一些记事卡，女士。我们来做一张记事卡吧。好的。好吧。这是一个非常书呆子的演员时刻。所以请忍受我。但我认为约翰作为吉姆在电话里和德克先生谈话时做得非常出色，当时他输掉了给德怀特的销售。哦，这是世界上最难的事情之一，进行一场虚假的单方面电话交谈。它有情感的起伏。是的。或者你在反应，像这样，他很兴奋，然后他很失望，然后他弄清楚了发生了什么。
And there's no one on the other line. No one. There's no one speaking to you. John is just doing that on his own. And I just sat there and I rewatched it. And John, I just want you to know you crushed that phone call. I did such a great job. Yeah. Now I have done films or I have done things where someone is on the other line. For example, in season nine, when Pam breaks down crying at her desk, they figured out a way to wire in John Krasinski live. So I could hear him in my ear. So there are times when there's a really emotional scene or a scene that really requires you to speak to the other actor, but like 90% of the time, you are just pretending someone's there. There's no one there. Yeah, exactly. And so John was just
电话那头没有人。没有人。没有人跟你说话。约翰只是自己在那做。我坐在那里，我重看了它。约翰，我只是想让你知道你搞定了那个电话。我做得太棒了。是的。现在我已经拍过电影或者做过一些事情，有人在电话那头。例如，在第九季，当帕姆在办公桌前崩溃大哭时，他们想出了一种方法，把约翰·卡拉辛斯基的声音实时连线进来。所以我可以在耳机里听到他。所以有时会有非常感人的场景，或者需要你和另一位演员交谈的场景，但90%的时间，你只是假装有人在那里。那里没有人。是的，没错。所以约翰只是
talking to Mr. Decker who wasn't there. And I just thought he did such a great job. So anyway, I just had to give a little love to JK. Yeah. And after that scene, when Jim finds out that he has lost the sale, that Dwight stole the sale, that is 25% of his income, he goes back into the conference room where Michael is wrapping things up and everyone is bored to tears. And that is when Pam falls asleep on Jim's shoulder. And we filmed that about, oh my goodness, like 15, 16 times that scene because this was our Jim Pam moment of the episode. This was it. And they really wanted to get these little Jim Pam moments just perfectly. I looked up this scene in the script and there is a piece of stage direction that BJ Novak wrote that I want to read for you because I think it is so perfect.
在和不在那里的德克先生说话。我只是觉得他做得太棒了。所以无论如何，我只是不得不给JK一点爱。是的。在那场戏之后，当吉姆发现他输掉了销售，德怀特偷走了销售，那是他收入的25%，他回到迈克尔正在总结事情的会议室，每个人都无聊透顶。就在那时，帕姆在吉姆的肩膀上睡着了。我们拍了大约，哦天哪，15、16次那个场景，因为这是我们这一集的吉姆和帕姆时刻。就是这个。他们真的想把这些吉姆和帕姆的小时刻拍得完美。我在剧本里查了这个场景，有一段BJ·诺瓦克写的舞台指导，我想读给你听，因为我觉得它太完美了。
He wrote, Jim reacts to Pam falling asleep on him like a butterfly has landed on his shoulder. Aw. Isn't that so poetic? That's so poetic. That is so sweet. And so that's what John had in his mind was that was his, you know, inspiration for how to react to that. That is so sweet. Like how special to have a butterfly land on your shoulder and you don't want to move and you don't want to disturb it. Oh, that is so sweet. Well, I wrote, you know, this is equally as just insightful, you guys. I wrote on my note card, what a great jam moment at the end and Jenna's skin looks flawless. Well, thank you, Angela, because I did notice in an earlier shot, there is a shot of my skin that looks just terrible. Well, we didn't have like any makeup on really, like at all, like
他写道，吉姆对帕姆在他身上睡着了的反应，就像一只蝴蝶落在了他的肩膀上。啊。那不是很诗意吗？那太诗意了。那太甜了。所以这就是约翰脑子里想的，那是他的，你知道，关于如何反应的灵感。那太甜了。就像蝴蝶落在你的肩膀上是多么特别，你不想动，也不想打扰它。哦，那太甜了。嗯，我写了，你知道，这同样是很有洞察力的，伙计们。我在我的记事卡上写了，最后是一个多么棒的吉姆和帕姆时刻，珍娜的皮肤看起来完美无瑕。嗯，谢谢你，安吉拉，因为我确实注意到在早些时候的一个镜头里，有一个我的皮肤看起来很糟糕的镜头。嗯，我们真的没有化什么妆，就像根本没有，就像
barely any makeup. We had powder blush and a little mascara. Right. And I had one strip of powder that wouldn't stick to my forehead anymore. So I don't know, Jenna, I thought your skin looked flawless. Well, you know what, to wrap it up, why don't we do one last fan question? Okay. Alexia asked if there were any scenes that were taken out that we wish had made it in? And I picked this fan question because my answer is yes. Okay, which one, Jenna? I was in it. Well, what is it? All right. So you remember earlier in the episode when Mr. Brown starts his training, he explains what a hero is and it's an acronym and then Dwight explains what he thinks a hero is. Well, after all that happened, there was a scene where Michael stands up and
几乎没化妆。我们有粉状腮红和一点睫毛膏。对。我有一条粉末不会再粘在我的额头上了。所以我不知道，珍娜，我觉得你的皮肤看起来完美无瑕。嗯，你知道吗，为了总结一下，我们为什么不做最后一个粉丝问题？好的。亚历克西娅问有没有什么被删掉的场景是我们希望保留下来的？我选择了这个粉丝问题，因为我的回答是肯定的。好的，哪一个，珍娜？我在里面。嗯，是什么？好吧。所以你记得在这一集早些时候，当布朗先生开始他的培训时，他解释了什么是英雄，这是一个首字母缩写，然后德怀特解释了他认为什么是英雄。嗯，在所有这些发生之后，有一个场景是迈克尔站起来，
creates his own acronym for sensitivity. And his words are inclusion, new attitude, colorblind, expectations, sharing and tolerance. And while he's saying these words, Dwight is writing them on a whiteboard. And I look at the whiteboard and I say, Michael, that spells incest. And then Steve tap dances and says, but it still works because incest is bad and discrimination is bad. But also incest is something that happens in your family. And the world is our family. Like it just, it's so crazy ramble. Just back away from it. Yeah, but he won't let it go. And then Pam has a talking head that says if he'd just rearranged the words, he could have spelled insect. And I just, I just remember shooting that scene. And every time I had to raise my hand
为“敏感”创造了他自己的首字母缩写。他的词是包容、新态度、色盲、期望、分享和宽容。当他说这些词时，德怀特把它们写在白板上。我看着白板说，迈克尔，那拼出来是“乱伦”。然后史蒂夫跳起踢踏舞说，但这仍然有效，因为乱伦是不好的，歧视也是不好的。但乱伦也是发生在家庭里的事情。而世界就是我们的家庭。就像它太疯狂了，胡言乱语。只是远离它。是的，但他不肯放过它。然后帕姆有一个谈话头说，如果他只是重新排列这些词，他就能拼出“昆虫”。我只是，我只是记得拍摄那个场景。每次我不得不举起手
and very matter of factly point out that it spells incest, then there was just this silence in the room as everyone took it in. And I was sad that went on the cutting room floor. That's very funny. So thank you, Alexia, for your question. All right, everybody. That was Diversity Day. And next week we're going to be talking about healthcare. Angela, what do you think about when you think about healthcare? Hot dog fingers. Hot dog fingers. We're going to talk about hot dog fingers with our first special guest, Rainn Wilson. Yes, that tall drink of water is calling in and we are going to talk about the episode with him. So be sure and tune in. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela
并且非常一本正经地指出它拼出来是“乱伦”，然后房间里就陷入了沉默，每个人都在消化它。我很遗憾它被剪掉了。那太搞笑了。所以谢谢你，亚历克西娅，你的问题。好了，大家。那是多元化日。下周我们将讨论医疗保健。安吉拉，当你想到医疗保健时，你会想到什么？热狗手指。热狗手指。我们将和我们的第一位特别嘉宾雷恩·威尔逊讨论热狗手指。是的，那个高个子正在打电话进来，我们将和他讨论这一集。所以一定要收听。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。
Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Heifer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Remember, you can listen to ad-free versions of Office Ladies on Stitcher Premium. For a free month of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·海弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。记住，你可以在Stitcher Premium上收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本。如需免费一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用代码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。